local restrictions are being imposed
today and uh Fraser m is in Arrington in
Lancashire for us Fraser bring us up to
data to on those uh restrictions as we
know them
now yeah the restrictions are going to
be broadly in line with those that we
saw introduced in the Northeast
yesterday although it has to be said
that not all Council leaders asked for
these restrictions to be brought in
unlike in the Northeast where the
leaders of those seven Council areas got
together approached the Secretary of
State and gave him a list of things that
they wanted to happen in terms of extra
restrictions and most of those were
imposed they haven't asked for these
restrictions directly not all of the
council leaders uh in Lancashire but
they have now been introduced and
they've been introduced uh in a wider
area than perhaps we first thought 13
Council areas we thought were going to
be uh given extra restrictions today in
Lancashire and it is now Pro shown to be
those areas along with some other areas
in West Yorkshire Kirkley cdale Bradford
areas like that that already have had
some restrictions put in place in the
past uh and they're going to be uh
they're going to be heightened even
further the majority of these involve
the mixture of households that's where
uh the people have identified that's
where the data identifies that the
majority of the transfer of this disease
is happening is within households and so
what they're trying to do is uh pretty
much across the whole of the north now
with a couple of exceptions is limit
households from mixing with each other
stopping them from mixing with each
other another area that's being added to
that list where in where restrictions
are going to be imposed now is in Mery
side and earlier on today the mayor of
Liverpool Joe Anderson said that when
these restrictions do come into effect
he'd like to see coid wardens being
given the same power as police officers
in order to be able to enforce them we
have uh the government making an
announcement 10 days ago that they were
going to introduce uh Marshals uh to
patrol at the streets we've yet to see
any further announcements or updates on
that what that's going to mean or what
it's going to entail and whether indeed
these Marshals who pays for them what
powers they have whether they work
alongside the police or can do things
without the police being there all these
things but Mery side police are working
extremely
hard and as well as these areas that are
going to have these extra restrictions
put in place there's also been movement
in terms of the watch list places like
uh scar swinden Great Yarmouth Norwich
broadland North Norfolk South Yorkshire
at South norfol kingslin West Norfolk
quite a long list there of places that
have now been put on the at risk area so
potentially we could be seeing those
face lockdown restrictions if their uh
stats continue to go the wrong way so at
the moment with there's about 10 million
people uh who are under extra
restrictions uh within England uh it's
now going to go up from Saturday when
these restrictions in Lancashire come in
and in mide by another million and a
half or so given the populations of
those areas so 11 and a half million
people by the end of the weekend will be
under some form of increased
restrictions in order to try and stop
these huge spikes uh in the infection
rate that we've been seeing for the past
two weeks now Fraser thank you